Il sait pas du tout où il est,
on a essayé de lui faire croire que c'était son habitacle naturel
c'est juste un jardin parisien
Le casting, déjà il est badass, il y a plein de copains
y'a Davy et Poulpe du Golden show, PV Nova, Greg et David du Palmashow, Antoine Daniel, AK
AK, qui est dans notre cœur et qu'on voulait absolument voir en Bruce Banner
surtout quand il paye ses fesses.
J'ai eu l'occasion d'être à poil sur le toit du Grand Rex et de m'exposer au tout Paris, donc ça c'est très bien.
Merci beaucoup Mr Alexandre Elman, le directeur du Grand Rex, qui nous a autorisé à tourner en haut du Grand Rex.
Et tu vois Jamy là, nous sommes sur le toit du Grand Rex !
Et c'est vachement grand !
Moi je trouve que c'est la vue la plus ouf de Paris que j'ai vu pour l'instant,
t'es en plein centre de Paris, t'as vue sur tout Paris.
Et c'est surtout intéressant de risquer ma vie en fait, juste pour ça !
Là c'est le vide.
Il est fou !
Tu peux checker nos souvenirs s'il te plaît parce que là, c'est flou.
Non, mais là, tu n'arriveras à rien. Ah, qu'il est nigaud !
C'est Julfou qui nous a appelé pour savoir si on voulait jouer dans ce sketch là,
puis à partir du moment où on a 30 ans, et on peut se déguiser en super-héros, je pense que
on a du retard quelque part
- Oui ça nous a plu.
Ca, c'est le pénis de Mr Fantastique, Mr élastique, c'est pas mal ! En fait, Julien et Raph, qui réalisent ce sketch,
ils ont des discussions à base de "tu crois pas que la bite faudrait la mettre plus haut?" "Ouais je pense !"
Alors là, en fait, le truc c'est que Greg va se casser une bouteille en sucre, donc des bouteilles spéciales,
Il va se la casser sur la tête, et on n'a qu'une seule bouteille, parce que ça coûte assez cher.
Donc, il faut pas qu'il se rate. Et donc là c'est un petit peu le stress.
Action !
Ouaaaaaaiiis !
Les sorties, clairement, les super-héros, s'ils se mettent une race, ils détruisent New-York.
On a un peu l'impression de découvrir une mine d'or : super héros + gueule de bois, ça n'a jamais été fait !
Et puis c'est drôle !
- Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait encore là ?
- Je sais pas, je me souviens juste de... j'sais pas
Ca me fait super plaisir d'être sur le sketch de Suricate. Non seulement, je suis dirigé par mon frère,
qui est habillé en Spiderman, pendant que moi je suis habillé en Deadpool, donc... y a rien de normal là dedans.
- Elle est pas mortelle cette soirée, là ?!
- C'est pas une soirée, putain, c'est un sketch Suricate !
- Ouais super !
- Tu t'appelles Greg, y a pas de musique.
- On devrait inventer des heures, entre 11 heures et midi, on devrait inventer genre...
- 4 heures
- 4 heures de plus
- On y va, en place, silence
Y a beaucoup de gens mais ce qui est ouf, c'est qu'on a une putain d'équipe, et que tout le monde est au taquet,
et ça c'est ouf en fait.
- En place, on fait le silence, s'il vous plaît, merci.
- Action !
Mettez-la là pour l'instant, laissez un peu de passage là.
Quand tu vois des gens mobilisés pour un truc que t'as écrit comme des connards, genre là, il lance un canard
Et là tu vois qu'il y a un canard
Ca va aller, ca va aller
Coupe pas, coupe pas. Viens on fait comme si c'était la suite, et la il fait "Aaaaaargh"
il crie trop comme un ouf, genre il en a marre !
Aaaaaaargh!
- Niveau son, je suis au max, t'as pas un truc pour booster ?
- J'sais pas, t'as qu'à mettre ta batterie là !
- Ah ouais grave !
Je suis en mode, il l'a retirée comme un bourrin quoi !
Ah merde, y avait un adaptateur ?
Et on va surement incruster la carte de la météo.
Mes photos à Arcachon, hop, je passe, je passe, je passe, ah excuse-moi, j'ai un appel, oui maman, oui c'est moi, ça va ?